today on the matt walsh show a pop
singer lasts about half a week after
provocatively declaring that women are
females her cave and surrender were
pathetic and embarrassing and inevitable
also today we're going to talk about why
cowards like this are the real villains
here i think also as the by
administration tries to recover from
biden's ron burgundy moment the contents
of hunter biden's icloud are allegedly
leaked on 4chan a female soldier openly
questions her loyalty to her country
after roe was overturned after years of
bragging about all of its women priests
and bishops the church of england now
says that the word woman has no
definition so that's a little bit
awkward and in our daily cancellation
the mainstream media finally
acknowledged what is a woman while i was
away on vacation the resulting hit piece
is even more disingenuous and ridiculous
than you might expect we'll talk about
all that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well our nation's authorities are now
openly admitting to having completely
missed the flashing red lights of
inflation and this administration's
failed economic policies treasury
secretary janet yellen admitted she was
wrong about the path inflation would
take she said quote there have been
unanticipated large shocks of the
economy that have boosted energy and
food prices and supply bottlenecks that
have affected our economy badly that at
the time i didn't fully understand
admitting that herself well there you
have it straight from the horse's mouth
i didn't fully understand she says that
the only thing that this administration
doesn't understand now i know you're
worried about affording basic
necessities in the months to come food
gas shelter everything else
but she didn't know you know it's not
her fault she just didn't know
it goes without saying that you can't
trust the so-called authorities on
economic policy which is why you should
invest at least some of your money in
gold and silver with birch gold group
protect your savings from a highly
turbulent economy by diversifying your
401k or ira into physical gold it's not
too late for you to take action right
now text walsh to 98 98 98 and get a
free info kit on diversifying and
protecting your savings with precious
metals birch gold group is an a plus
rating with the better business bureau
countless five-star reviews
and thousands of satisfied customers as
well so text walsh to 989898
and get real advice from birch gold
today again text walsh to 989898
to claim your free no obligation info
kit on protecting your savings with gold
well i officially returned to uh my show
from vacation today which means that in
preparation for this event i had to make
my official return
to twitter yesterday i had only ventured
you know back into that overflowing
cyber septic tank for a few hours before
my name was trending and i thought that
at first you know i was trending because
everybody was welcoming and being back
with well wishes and warm salutations
and all that but it turns out that um
most of the messages were considerably
less
friendly i guess that's no surprise on
second thought the conversation seemed
to revolve around a brief argument that
i had with jk rowling on sunday because
of course the first thing that i do when
i come back from vacation and i'm really
well rested is i pick a fight with a
random famous person but before we get
to that we need to back up
all the way to ancient history which was
last tuesday when i was still out
fishing and the singer macy gray was
igniting a media
firestorm by controversially suggesting
that women exist
so during her appearance on piers morgan
where i think she was promoting an album
or something like that she uh the the
conversation kind of drifted to the
topic of gender and morgan
posed the ultimate question of course
the question of our generation which um
uh gray had at first no trouble
answering at all
i'm sure you've heard this this clip
already but uh let's play it again just
for our own enjoyment here it is
if i asked you what a woman is what
would you say
i would say uh a human being with uh
boobs
how are you to start there yeah i mean
the dictionary is quite straightforward
it just says
adult female right
now a lot of people yeah see that now
that's a little getting confusing the
whole he she they that's good that's
good and i'm not sure why really it's
it's a bit like this whole issue of
transgenders in sport it's like i
support all trans rights to fairness and
equality
but not where you have people born to
obvious physical superior bodies
transitioning and then thrashing the
women at their sport i totally agree and
i will say this and everybody's going to
hate me but as a woman just because you
go change your parts doesn't make you a
woman right sorry
you feel that
i know that for a fact like if you want
me to call you or her i will because
that's what you want but that doesn't
make you a woman just cause i call you
or her and just because you got a
surgery
so
thus began the usual circus routine
after saying this objectively true and
normal thing
gray was reviled by the left slammed as
a transphobe and a bigot and she's you
know well she's she's marginalizing and
erasing trans people
through her refusal to allow women to be
marginalized and erased that's basically
the accusation
and meanwhile on the other side of it
the right hailed her as a hero you know
a courageous warrior triumphing over
cancel culture she was applauded for for
standing firm and and being bold in the
face of the backlash
but the applause
as is almost always the case
unfortunately came too soon uh gray made
it all of about three days
before buckling and on thursday of the
very same week the singer made the
traditional pilgrimage to a morning tv
show to express her deep regrets and
sorrow and to beg for absolution she
explained that over the previous couple
of days the experience of having a bunch
of blue-haired freaks scream screaming
at her had been very educational and it
had been very enlightening she'd learned
a lot from the blue haired freaks that's
my words not hers i'm paraphrasing in
fact she'd learned that
everything she thought she knew about
the world was wrong biology is a myth
and that she as a woman
doesn't actually exist she learned all
this in two or three days
and they had taught her this
by crying and screaming it was the most
educational temper tantrum she'd ever
witnessed apparently let's watch that
i never of course meant to hurt anybody
with with what i said i'm not
i'm actually a huge uh
i think it takes a lot of courage to be
yourself to go out in the world and be
honest about who you are
and uh so i think anyone who is uh
in the lgbt community is a hero and sets
an example for all of us with that you
know
um
so i said some things uh that that uh
didn't go over well
but um my intention was never to to hurt
anybody i feel bad uh
that i did hurt some people
and and i think it's it's um
you know it's just about education it's
about conversation and and us getting to
a point where we
understand each other and and um
and and that that only happens with you
know i've learned a lot through this
so i think that that was one of the
reasons uh it might have happened just
it was a huge learning experience for me
you know what i i think you you you can
like i said in there you can call
yourself what like you
you whoever you believe you are and and
no one can dictate that for you or take
that away from you you know
i think life is an education process the
more you sit with people the more you
talk to people it changes your
perspective so has has your perspective
changed do you feel
i've learned so much and and i think um
you know being a woman is a vibe and
it's something i'm i'm very proud of
and it's very precious to me and
i i think that if you
in your heart feel that that's what you
are then that's what you are regardless
of what anybody says
or thinks you know what i'm saying
well it's a good thing you know that all
the groveling bases were covered there
she didn't skip any of the steps she was
very thorough in that way the script was
followed with precision
uh and and though we we've grown so
accustomed to seeing this pageant of
humiliation play out it never gets any
easier to watch at least not for me
anyway each time i feel like i'm
watching somebody cut their own heart
out of their chest it's grotesque and
disgusting and humiliating but weirdly
fascinating you're just kind of glued to
the screen watching this sick display
um and you you can't look away as much
as you want to because we know the steps
here step one
the penitent
claims that she's learned a lot and
she's been educated that's the necessary
first step never explains what she's
learned exactly or how she learned it or
exactly what insights her critics
offered to her that's because there was
there was no insight unless guttural
screaming and demonic convulsing counts
as an insight i don't know and then step
two she she flatters the rage mob you
know she lays down her offerings at
their feet
she bows before them in worship adoring
them declaring in this case that
everybody in the lgbt community is a
hero all of them because um of course it
requires true heroism
to belong to the most protected
privileged and coddled and applauded
group of people to ever exist on planet
earth that requires heroism to do that
and then step three she finally and
fully renounces all of her past beliefs
she renounces reality and truth itself
she renounces renounces her own
existence really
proclaiming that contrary to what she
had always thought up until about
breakfast time that morning there is no
objective or biological basis to
womanhood
being a woman is as she put it
a vibe
you know it's just a vibe a woman isn't
anything but you know if you feel like
you are one
then you are one and what you are
is nothing
all women are nothing
and everybody is invited to join them in
their nothingness
now of course
if being a woman is just a vibe
then it doesn't really make a lot of
sense for men to take drugs or get
surgeries as part of their transition
process
there is no such thing as a vibe surgery
you can't surgically implant or remove a
vibe right you can't go to the doctor
and say uh you know i i just i want to
have a certain vibe can you give me a
cert that doesn't make any sense
if it's all about the vibe if it's about
the feeling then the whole gender
transition industry makes no sense and
it's built on a false premise so it
turns out that either way
whether the claims made by gender
ideology are wrong or right
the whole process of gender transition
is nonsensical and false either way
but as we've learned we cannot expect
the proponents of this idea to notice
these kinds of contradictions or care
about them if they do notice them
this all brings us back to the beginning
of our story i criticized
macy gray for you know on twitter for
being a gutless coward which is what she
is
and after some pushback to that i
tweeted this i said sorry but women who
publicly renounce the definition of
woman for fear of mean comments from
trans activists deserve all the scorn
they get that kind of gutless cowardice
is exactly what got us into this
position in the first place that's what
i said okay
now a little while later jk rowling who
famously has stood up courageously
against the trans mob uh responded to me
with a defense of gray and of other
women who have similarly folded like
cheap lawn chairs
rowling tweeted in response to me she
said
endless death threats and rape threats
threats of loss of livelihood employers
targeted physical harassment family
addresses posted online with pictures of
bomb making manuals aren't mean comments
if you don't yet understand what happens
to women who stand up on this issue back
off
she said talking to me
now lots of other feminists in the
so-called turf camp or the gender
critical camp as they prefer to call
themselves most of them they've echoed
and agreed with this sentiment from
rallying in fact um
i've heard this from feminists
quite a lot since my film came out that
that it's easy for me they say i don't
know what it's like
okay
i don't have to make the same kind of
sacrifices i don't put the same things
on the line i don't get treated the same
way
nobody attacks me the way they attack
women who speak out
and now rowling whose courage on this
issue i as i said i really respect and
i've said that many times
is singing the same tune
but she's completely wrong of course
and it just shows how feminists who
criticized the trans agenda even though
they're right about the issue of
transgenderism they're still hamstrung
and handicapped by left-wing identity
politics and victimology
they can't accept an alliance
with a man because they resent us for
our perceived privilege
even though it's a privilege they've
completely invented in their heads
because the fact is that nearly
everything she describes
the things that i can't understand
supposedly because they only happen to
women supposedly
they have happened to me with great
frequency and ferocity i would say over
the past month and before that but
especially over the past month
i've had many death threats i've been
doxed many times okay i don't i don't
the thing is i don't talk about these
things a lot i mention them here and
there i don't spend a lot of time
talking about them
but i can assure you they are happening
i have been threatened
harassed insulted they've tried to
de-platform me they tried to get me
fired they tried to get my advertisers
to boycott etc and so forth over and
over and over again
um i don't doubt
at all
that trans activists are vicious
monsters towards any woman who defies
them but the operative aspect there is
defies them
not women
they cannot tolerate defiance from
anyone
the survival of their fragile worldview
as we've seen depends on silencing all
of the opposition no matter who it's
coming from
doesn't matter if it's the idea that
if it's coming from a from a white
conservative man that they're gonna lay
off no he's good he's one of the good
ones let's leave him alone
it's just uh it's hilarious
but here's the thing
if i had over the past month or any if i
any time in the future
cave to the mob and pull a macy gray
i would deserve scorn too endless
amounts of it okay i i would i'm telling
you right now if i ever were to do that
you should scorn me and despise me for
that
now it's not going to happen happen i
can assure you that
because i would quite literally rather
be dead than surrender to these people
i'd rather take a bullet to the head
than debase myself the way macy gray did
and it wouldn't even be a difficult
choice
but if that were not the case
and i crumbled under the onslaught and
turned traitor on truth for the sake of
protecting myself i would be i would be
a a worse villain in this story
than any individual trans militant
because as i said in the original tweet
the cowards are the ones who got us into
this mess
why is that well
because there were never enough and
still are not enough trans militants to
forcibly drag our society into the mass
epidemic of madness that we're currently
experiencing they can't do it on their
own
without our consent as much as they
would like to as much as they're trying
to they can't
in order for this to happen it has it
has required and will continue to
require the acquiescence of countless
people who know better who know the
truth
but implicitly or in many cases
explicitly renounce and disavow that
knowledge in order to preserve their own
comfort and their own safety but most of
the time it's just their own comfort
because most of the time their safety is
not really in jeopardy sometimes it is
but in most cases it's not
you know i really don't think that
anyone was going to go kill macy gray
because of uh because of a you know a
one minute conversation she had on piers
morgan
i wouldn't put anything past these
people but i really doubt that was gonna
happen
what she was trying to protect was her
financial security and just her comfort
and and really she just wanted to get
along with her hollywood friends and her
friends in the music industry and that's
what she was trying to protect
every time a coward collapses like this
betraying themselves and all the rest of
us on the team common you know on team
common sense when they when they when we
are betrayed in this way as we are so
often
they only make it that much harder for
whoever the mob turns its sights on next
so it's not a victimless
crime here
the mob is emboldened and fueled by
every person who sells their souls to it
they are vultures who feed on the
dignity that you abandon and leave on
the floor
they they feast on your
subservience and your submission
and your self-debasement
the only way to stop them is to starve
them of this fuel
is to look them in the eyes and say no i
apologize for nothing i am right you are
wrong
now go scream about it some more you
damned hobgoblins i don't care you don't
scare me
and laugh in their face that's how you
handle it
anything less than that
and you're part of the problem
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well if you like skydiving great but you
got to get your will finalized before
you go skydiving it's just a fact that
100 of people who skydive and 100 of
people who breathe
will die okay in fact 100 of people who
do anything at all
anywhere will die so whether you're
going out with a bang skydiving you're
going to live another 100 years or
whatever it is a will isn't about you
it's about your loved one it's about uh
the really hard decisions they need to
make if something were to happen to you
don't make your family make hard
decisions when all they should be
focused on is grieving instead give them
all the answers like life support or
pull the plug buried or cremated i mean
if you die skydiving there's not gonna
be a life support issue because you're
just gonna be a pancake on the ground
but you get it there's a lot of
decisions to make um whatever it happens
to be you need to have the will in place
but here's the deal the judge who it
takes over if you don't have a will they
don't know who your best friend is or
who you trust to raise your kids the
fact is a will is something that can
take as little as five minutes to set up
and if you don't do it you're acting
selfishly so go to epicwheel.com use
promo code walsh and i'll even save you
ten percent i mean come on you can
literally have a comprehensive will
starting at 119 and if you don't have a
will you're gift wrapping money to the
state by letting the state use its will
to decide everything for you don't trust
the state to make any decision for your
family go to epicwhell.com use promo
code walsh and just get it done
all right well as uh mentioned i was on
vacation last week i didn't tell you i
was going on vacation because i thought
that it'd be best for you to experience
the trauma unexpectedly and so that's
the strategy i went with and in fact i'm
still sort of on vacation not really at
least i'm in the place where i was
vacationing
and i asked the daily wire could i stay
here for a few more like a couple more
weeks and and do the show from here and
they very eagerly and quickly said yes
and at first i was happy about that but
then i was sort of offended that they
were so eager and happy for me not to be
there i try not to think about it very
much
um anyway the drive up here was
is about 20 hours um
all told which we did you know with
stops which we didn't about a day and a
half
with four kids
and um it was a little rough i'll be
honest with you for the first 17 hours
but we really hit a stride after that
point i think the worst thing that
happened though on the way up here is um
and this is about seven i don't know
like 18 hours into it and we were just
disheveled
and annoyed and everything as you can
imagine and we stopped at a at a uh a
chick-fil-a
and i'm in the parking lot with my kids
my wife had to run in to you know go to
the bathroom
and uh i'm like yelling at my kids
because
just because we've been in the car for
18 hours and they were and they were
going out of their minds and saying so
i'm trying to it's like i'm scolding
them in that sort of helpless way that
you do when you're in a car with them
and there's nothing you could there's no
way to really punish them
you know immediately anyway and so i'm
doing that and then i look over and
there's this car parked right next to us
looking at me like kind of smiling
because they're fans of the show and
they're witnessing all of this
and um
and so then we had a little bit of an
awkward conversation but then
the worst part about this and i just
have to tell you this i was waiting for
this to be a scandal and everyone to
find out about it but now now i'm just
going to tell you myself
the worst part is
i thought about afterwards
is that i was sitting in the passenger
seat of the car and my wife came in and
sat in the driver's seat
and we had this conversation with them
and they didn't say anything but i can
only imagine if they're members of the
sweet baby gang
the judgment they must have been
thinking in their heads towards me that
i was not driving the car and i just
want to say for the record
i did 18 hours of this drive
after that i said fine i'll let my wife
drive because i might fall asleep and
kill everybody if i don't so i did make
that decision
but
i would not uh
i wouldn't begrudge them
thinking less of me after seeing that
because i would anytime i see a man not
driving his own car i i judge him and
then so i guess this is right this is
like punishment for the from the
universe
and it sends a message that uh what i
should have done is put my own pride and
masculinity above safety that's what i
should have done i made the wrong choice
i paid for it all right so
let's start with this this is a good way
to start off i think camilla harris was
interviewed on cbs over the weekend and
had another moment of sheer articulate
brilliance
and i i don't know each one just gets
better than the last in my opinion
uh let's let's watch this check it out
did democrats fail past democratic
presidents congressional leaders to not
codify roe v wade over the past five
decades i do believe that we
should have rightly believed but we
certainly believe that certain issues
are just settled
certain issues are just settled clearly
we're not no that's right and that's why
i do believe that we are living
sadly in um real unsettled
times
really so just a quote
i do believe that we have rightly
believed but we certainly believed that
certain issues are just settled certain
issues are just settled and that's why i
do believe that we are living in real
unsettled times remember what i told you
okay this is the only way to understand
camilla well not understand her that's
not exactly the right word i'm looking
for um this is the well it's it's a way
of not it's not a way of understanding
the meaning behind her words because
there is no meaning but it's a way of
understanding why she has no meaning
when she speaks you know why is she
babbling and it's because as i've told
you and you really heard it there i
think perfect example of it is that she
never knows
what word she's going to say next okay
each
every time she speaks for her speaking
is a is a is a continuous game of word
association and so she just throws one
word out there
and it's it's just a journey she just
decides what word's gonna be next and
she stitches it together throws a period
in there a question mark in there but it
doesn't really mean anything and she's
just saying words um but that's why you
find she gets into into these rhythms
where she'll use the same word over and
over again in slightly different
contexts
and it doesn't make any sense at all but
it's just word associations she's just
kind of she's just kind of freestyling
as she goes that's the way she speaks um
and it's it's it is in some ways kind of
remarkable
um
and i guess this is what happens when
you are
totally vacuous you have nothing to say
you have no content at all inside your
head now that's not that's not
remarkable for a politician that's the
case for most of them that's why i hate
almost all of them
but
then on top of that you have no bs game
whatsoever you are you are not a bs
artist okay you are very much an amateur
so when you're not able to bs your way
through it now most politicians are at
least decently okay at that part of it
uh but yet you have nothing to say you
end up with camilla harris
and
this though did not manage to overshadow
i think the ron burgundy moment from joe
biden which
i want to play this clip because then it
ties into another
story that i want to talk about
and i'm sure you've heard this already
but we're going to play it again just
for again for our own enjoyment here's
joe biden reading the prompters a few
days before this
verbatim
and um and and literally including the
stuff that's supposed to be
parenthetical that he wasn't supposed to
read out loud but of course he did let's
let's listen to that again
it is noteworthy that the percentage of
women who registered to vote and cast a
ballot is consistently higher than the
percentage of the men who do so end of
quote repeat the line
women are not without electoral and or
political or or maybe precisely not and
or or political power
that's another saying you the women of
america can determine the outcome
of this
issue now as the federalist reports the
white house uh over the last few days
they've tried to clean that up a little
bit and they actually changed the
official white house transcript anytime
the president speaks
you can uh go to the
the white house website and they have
official transcripts of whatever he said
and for the
you know the person transcribing joe
biden it's always that's always a
challenge just like the
the sign language interpreter is in a
very challenging position with joe biden
and the person transcribing him is in
challenging position also
so they
misquote him as saying
end of quote
let me repeat the line but he didn't say
let me review the line he just said
repeat the line because that was the
prompter person behind the prompter
instructing him repeat the line he just
said and said he just he just read it
out loud
now
this to me
this kind of story
to me is even bigger than
this which i'll which i'll get to now
this is washington examiner
it says
a lot of this is uh there's a lot of
this that still has not been officially
confirmed and all that and uh and you
know to the extent that we wait for the
mainstream media to officially confirm
anything that just means that never will
be that's always the position we're in
whenever there's embarrassing
information about a democrat circulating
out there this is what the washington
examiner reports they say
the contents of hunter biden's icloud
account have allegedly been hacked by
users of the 4chan community who posted
screenshots purported to be
from his phone from hunter biden's phone
and his computer on the website's main
political forum late saturday night
administrators on the image board moved
quickly and the hours after the content
was posted to pull down threads that
included materials from the alleged leak
leaving many on the site which is known
for featuring some of the most salacious
subject matter on the internet furious
there's been no
of course the white house has not issued
any statement about this whatsoever the
controversy could not immediately be
verified by the washington examiner and
a white house representative did not
immediately respond to a request for
comment big surprise there it was also
not immediately clear if the contents of
the 4chan leak included any materials
from the younger biden's infamous laptop
of which the washington examiner
verified the authenticity earlier this
year so there's a lot of um
again supposedly from
from hunter biden's icout icloud account
someone over 4chan was able to hack into
it and they release a lot of stuff and
it's circulating out there on the
internet uh it's incredibly embarrassing
and disgusting and criminal there's
videos allegedly of hunter biden there's
one where he i have to keep saying
allegedly put the scare quotes around
that um
where he's measuring out crack appears
to be measuring out crack
on like a scale and he and he takes a
video of him he films himself measuring
out the crack and then i guess arguing
with his crack dealer about whether it's
you know enough crack so even though
this is from 4chan and it has not been
independently verified it's it
my
interpretation personally is that the
images and the videos and everything
do seem to be
very legitimate i mean it just appears
either that or it's the most
it's either either the content is
legitimate
or it's the most
deviously and expertly done
um
you know photoshop fake that we've ever
seen it's like one of those two options
but it appears to be
pretty real to me anyway
right and yet
um i still think
the bigger story is
the teleprompter thing or things similar
to that with joe biden he falls off a
bicycle that's the bigger story to me
because i continue to believe
that the best argument against joe biden
the most potent criticism
is that he is a senile incompetent
destroying the country
that's it
he's senile and incompetent that's why
he can't even read a prompter
he can't ride a bicycle without falling
off of it
and he's destroying the country
he's the worst president of american
history
he's had the worst first two years first
half a term or whatever almost half a
term that we've ever seen he's done more
damage
in in in two years than any politician
has ever been able to do
in in this country
not an exaggeration i don't even think
that there's
there might be a little bit of
competition for that for that title but
but not much i think he's pretty far
ahead of the pack
and that's what matters about him for me
um
not so much that his son is a crackhead
now that doesn't mean that it's
irrelevant it is relevant
if all this stuff is legitimate then
there's a lot i mean you have crimes
being committed by the president's son
who's by the way not in jail
that's relevant
it's an issue of law and order of
justice
also when you want to look into ties
between you know the all the different
ways i mean that's the sun we're talking
about but all the business ties and
everything to link them together um so
it's not that it's irrelevant
it's just that especially from a
political standpoint
it requires explanation
like
when you go to the average person who
doesn't follow this stuff very closely
and especially as we get into
2024 and the election cycle if he
actually runs again and you're trying to
explain to this person like why they
shouldn't vote for biden we don't want
biden in office again
if you lead with hunter biden the
average person is going to say well
that's just that's his loser kid like
that doesn't
how does that affect anything
how does that tie to him how does he
have anything to do with that well he
does have something to do with it but
then you gotta explain it and it becomes
this kind of circuitous path you have to
follow and meanwhile over here you've
got this really solid understandable
case
and things like the teleprompter they
put it in front of everybody's face in a
in a in a really clear way
that this guy is senile and incompetent
and he's doing a horrible job he's
destroying the country
that's what we should be hammering i
made the same point during
the 2020 election cycle when hunter's
laptop came out
yeah it's a story it's relevant
became even bigger story but in the ways
that big tech tried to censor it
this kind of conspiracy between big tech
and media and and the democrats and all
that that was a big story
but as i said at the time that can't be
our closing argument going into the
election because it's not the most
powerful one the most powerful one is
joe biden himself this guy himself
i still think that the case that's the
case here which means we talk about it
but i don't want to get
especially as we get into election
seasons and we go back to the hunter
biden thing it just makes me nervous
because i'm like are we going to
distract
ourselves from the fact from just
hammering on the fact over and over and
over again the president is senile has
no idea what he's doing and is ruining
the country
even if all of his children are totally
squared away
you know did that still be the case
all right let's move to this so a female
army soldier has recorded a tick tock
video questioning her own loyalty to the
united states because of the roe
decision
and this is the kind of thing this is
the woke privilege that you have that
you can
record a video like this active duty
military and put it out on the internet
with no fear of of anything happening to
you and so here's what she posted look
at this
i have thoughts
i have thoughts and i have questions
and
it happened
it happened
i woke up from a nap to this
on deployment i woke up from a nap to
this news
america is waking up to this news
i just extended my contract
to continue serving this country a week
ago
how am i supposed to swear to support
and defend
the constitution
and a country
that treats its women like second-class
citizens
how am i supposed to do that how am i
supposed to do that with pride
how am i supposed to do that with love
and honor
how am i supposed to wake up every day
and put on a freaking uniform that says
united states army when the united
states doesn't even give a rats
about me it gives more of a rats
about the guns they're allowed to buy
that kill the children that i'm forced
to give birth to think about that
oh that's so funny
think about it you know think about that
utter total nonsense it really gives you
something to think about i guess
this is uh of course now i just looked
up for an update and i didn't i didn't
see one so because i'm i'm
naively
optimistically looking for
some news that this woman is being at
least reprimanded i mean she should be
kicked out of the military there's no
question about that you're you're active
duty military and you're publicly
declaring
um that you're not sure about your
loyalty to the united states you are
you're publicly questioning your own
loyalty tonight to the united states and
questioning whether you can fulfill the
the oath that you took
when you became a member of the military
and
she's allowed to continue of course
because this is this is what happens
this is the consequence that we're going
to leave aside like the content of
everything she said the claim she made
obviously all that is just
total nonsense women are second-class
citizens because they can't kill their
children no that actually as a woman
if you can't kill your children
then that puts you in the same class as
everybody else and everybody else only
includes one other category which would
be men okay
we that's the position that we've been
in
um
since
since the the dawn of the nation i mean
that's that's the position we've always
always been in which is that we cannot
legally
murder our children
um
and that's the position that everybody
should be in you should not be able to
legally murder your children so that's
the law
that we've been under
even after roe v wade
but if you're a woman then you had a you
know about a half century period
where you were put
you were in fact
made into uh you you were put above
men in that you were given this this
legal privilege if we could even call it
that
you know you became
you alone
had authority over the life and death
of your child and in a way that the the
the father of the child could not
participate
so removing that privilege and again i
hesitate to use the word privilege i
don't mean that in the sense of being a
good thing obviously uh that entitlement
that whatever you want to call it that
extra power of judge jury and execution
over your own children removing that
from you doesn't make you a second-class
citizen that actually brings you closer
to equality so what you're experiencing
what this woman in the video what she's
experiencing and how distraught she's
feeling and all the distress
that is the feeling
of getting closer to actual equality
but for you the trip to this is why it's
it's so distressing for you and so
difficult is that for you the trip to
equality means going down basically
doesn't mean climbing up
now when you climb up and you achieve
equality because in the past your
equality had been taken from you
and you were made unequal
you were put below other people and then
you're given equality now this is a
celebratory occasion right but in this
case this is a legal power which you
never should have had
it's been taken away a privilege has
been taken away and now you're equal
with men and that neither man nor woman
can legally kill a child
in in some u.s states anywhere and then
plenty of other states uh they still
have that privilege
but leaving aside i just said i was
gonna leave aside the content because
it's nonsense but i couldn't help myself
uh if we could leave that aside for a
moment
what she's doing here obviously should
be not only getting shouldn't mean not
only getting kicked out of the military
but being arrested also
because you are
now by your own profession a traitor to
the united states
you know questioning your own loyalty to
the united states but this is the
consequence of
bringing people into the military
in a way that that's uh uh
uh where we are
presenting the military as not a place
of uniformity
a place where you work together as a
team
um a place of uh discipline and
obedience i mean that's what the
military has always been historically
both in this country and every other
country on earth up until very recent
times
but now
we sell the military and i say we i mean
like the the
bureaucrats in dc sell it through their
recruitment campaigns they sell as an
opportunity to
express your individualism an
opportunity to you know truly
be yourself uh to truly you know fulfill
your own personal
destiny and all that kind of stuff so
when you
when you highlight
individuality in the military
this is what you end up with
people on camera
about a supreme court decision
and saying well i don't know if i can
defend the united states anymore
which which by the way that's that's not
much of a threat to us like if you feel
like you can't do your job anymore then
please just leave you should be kicked
out you should be fired you should be
arrested but you're not going to be
so if you feel like you can't do it then
absolutely just it's
we're not going to be any worse off
without you that woman in the tick tock
video we're not going to be any worse
off without you
i don't think anyone if you leave the
military i don't think anyone is going
to feel less safe now that you're not in
it
so take some solace in that i guess
one other thing kind of on the same
topic this is from the new york post
it says a pregnant texas woman who was
given a traffic ticket for driving solo
in an hov lane and tends to fight the
citation arguing that her fetus should
be considered a separate person given
the lone star state's views and abortion
mother b brandy baton 34 told the dallas
morning news that she was given the
ticket on june 29th after being pulled
over by police while driving on a
highway near the city
she told the newspaper quote i was
driving to pick up my son i knew i
couldn't be a minute late so i took the
hov lane as i exited hiv lane there was
a checkpoint at the end of the exit i
slammed on my brakes and i was pulled
over by police
uh the cop asked if she had a passenger
with her and she responded that in fact
she did i pointed to my stomach and said
my baby girl is right here this she is a
person
um he said oh no it's going to be two
people outside of the body that's what
it has to be
so now she's fighting in a court saying
that well
it's pretty clear from the context here
that she's she's pro-abortion and so
this was her way this is a kind of
gotcha moment here
um against the the pro-lifers saying hey
you see what happens
you see you get rid of abortion and now
all of a sudden there's confusion in the
hov lane
and i guess she expects that we as
pro-lifers will say well never mind that
well i thought that it would be good to
stop killing babies but if we don't if
you're telling me that uh that getting
rid of abortion means that there's
slight confusion hov lane well the never
mind let's just kill the babies again
that's a price that we simply can't pay
now there is an easy way around this if
you want to preserve the integrity of
the hov lane and also
um not kill babies like if you want to
do both of those things the way around
it is to say that you have to have
passengers in a passenger seat that's
what we mean by hov so
that's the way around it very just a
really simple clarification i think we
get around this or
here's what i would prefer
just get rid of the stupid hov lane to
begin with
okay so which which is which is not a
bad thing as far as i'm concerned
so this is another example of democrats
proposing something
very attractive
as a way to punish us for banning
abortion
and in this case the the implication is
that we'd have to abolish the carpool
lane
if we don't have abortion anymore
which great let's do that because the
left lane is supposed to be for people
driving fast who cares how many people
are in the in the car with you
if you want to be in the left most lane
then you should just be driving fast you
should be driving a lot faster than the
cars in the other lane that's the only
qualification that there should be on
the left lane and that should be rigidly
enforced as far as i'm concerned
i mean people who go
like five miles under the limit in the
in the speed in the fast lane
like forget about finding we should be
pulling them over and putting them in
jail for for 30 days to let them think
about it
um and that's fine with me so let's just
do that
uh but this is this is what this is what
the democrats have been doing is in
proposing things
that
like claiming that there are
implications to get rid of getting rid
of abortion and those implications are
actually great here's another one this
is a jack
uh
cochiarella i guess he's a democrat
strategist he tweeted this yesterday or
a couple days ago he said if republicans
really believe life begins at conception
shouldn't someone who is pregnant be
allowed to claim their baby as a
dependent on their taxes
sounds great let's do that too it's
fantastic get rid of the hov lane only
have a fast lane you drive you drive
fast in the left lane fantastic um claim
and depend you know you can claim
your unborn child as it depends on your
taxes that means a tax break
so that's great too
what does he imagine this is a democrat
strategist who has no idea he's supposed
to be a strategist for the democrats
which should mean that he's an expert on
republicans and conservatives his
opponents he should know us
like the back of his own hand he has no
understanding of us whatsoever
he thinks that he can threaten us with a
tax break
this is just like the ones that you know
the people that are saying well if we
don't have abortion then that means that
we're we're gonna have to have
abstinence
before marriage
right it's the end of hookup culture
great awesome well if we don't have
abortion well that means that we have to
require men
all right
well if we don't have abortion that
means we have to require men to uh care
for their babies
like from conception
you wouldn't want that would you no i do
want that all this is great abstinence
before marriage get rid of the carpool
lane tax breaks men taking care of their
kids
these are according to the opponents
of um
of pro-lifers according to the pro
boards themselves these are the
consequences of getting rid of abortion
so it's just it's win upon win upon win
i see nothing but upside and when i
think that we've seen all the upside we
could possibly see they give us some
more upside
and the great thing is that i didn't
need any upside other than
we're not killing babies anymore that
would've been good enough for me i
didn't need any of this other this extra
stuff but this is just you know whipped
cream cherries sprinkles on top this is
everything we got the whole ice cream
sundae now
um
all right one other quick thing i want
to mention before i get to the comment
section it says from the daily mail so
the church of england has admitted
that it does not have a definition of
the word woman a bishop said yesterday
that the meaning of the word used to be
self-evident but he added that there are
now complexities associated with gender
identity which a church project about
sexuality in relationships is exploring
so this is their official statement
they're exploring
what a woman is but right now there's no
official definition the thing that makes
this so fantastic
is that for years and years the church
of england has bragged about that the
fact that they have woman priests and uh
woman bishops they had their first their
first woman priest was back in the 1990s
and they were they were one of the the
earliest churches to you know institute
this policy of having woman priests and
then they had women bishops and
everything and they've been bragging
about that for years up until 30 seconds
ago
and now they're saying well on second
thought i don't actually know what a
woman is it's
forget all of that
the first one i looked this up the first
woman priest angela berners-wilson in
1994 was the first woman ordained as a
priest in the church of england and
she's been very excited about that for
the last um
you know for the last few decades and
she's been talking that's now been this
has been taken away from from angela
berners-wilson from father angela
berners-wilson this is taken away
because we don't even know what a woman
is so how can we talk about
uh how can we celebrate having woman
priests and women bishops
the left continues to eat itself and
it's just a glorious sight to behold now
let's get to our comment section
[Music]
i'll be honest guys this job uh it
really gets hard um all i do day all i
do all day long is i just watch debunk
and cancel stupid people
some days my producers make me sit
behind this desk for hours on end
watching purple-haired weirdos attempt
to explain their gender-neutral pronouns
to me it's no easy task and it's the
only way that i've found to cope with
this torture is with hallo hallow is the
number one christian prayer app in the
u.s it's like calm or head space
but it's rooted in catholic faith as
opposed to the religion of leftism hallo
offers over 5 000 audio guided prayers
meditations christian music tracks as
well some of those popular prayers
include the daily rosary gospel reading
and the daily psalm as well with bishop
barron they also have prayers led by
mark wahlberg mario lopez jim kavisel uh
jonathan rooney
hallow helps me find peace and calm
throughout the day even as crazy left
just yell at me through a tiny screen
you can let hallow help you find your
piece also so go to hallow.com
matt walsh and get a extended
three-month trial during which you'll
have access to all 5 000 plus meditation
and prayers that's hallow.com matt walsh
for three months free reclaim your piece
in this crazy world download hello today
well we didn't have uh a show last week
so we don't have show comments for the
comment section uh instead i thought
that i'll read
some comments under a video we posted
while we were away we posted a bunch of
new content even though we weren't here
which you can go to my youtube channel
if you haven't and and check some of
that out um and i think the most
important video that we put out i would
i ranked the five worst superheroes
and because i'm of course an expert on
the subject
it turns out that the worst superheroes
are all the female ones
i didn't decide that okay this is not my
well it was my list but yeah i i was
just looking at the facts as all and
as it turned out it just it just kind of
it shook out in a way where it turned
out that um
that
all the the worst superheroes
were women
and so there were a lot of interesting
comments that video i thought i'd read a
few of them
this one's from lulu
says matt matt matt were you given any
context for these characters black widow
isn't just a skinny little female she's
one of the most talented assassins in
the mcu's world
as a child she was indoctrinated into
the red room after she graduated from
the red room she spent many years
working for the kgb
before defecting to work as an agent of
shield she mastered not only martial
arts but also marksmanship interrogation
and so much more
the reason she's so skilled is because
she has no superpowers
wait what
she had to work hard to become strong
but she isn't just some overpowered
omnipotent character she has her
strength this goes on and on and on
forever this person's like a biographer
of black widow from from marvel universe
um
and and then he continues
i think this is allegedly a group oh
also lulu so you know these days who
knows
what person would be attached to that
name he said that uh let's see
having got intel she needed she dropped
the helpless act and took down the
general and his men who had all let down
their guard still think she's a skinny
little female man yeah i do okay because
the look
uh
as i said in that video again really
important issue is that
she not only do we have the absurdity
of a female action hero who's just like
beating up
a bunch of men all at once well not even
all at once because you notice the bad
guys this happens in a lot of action
films but especially the ones where
there's a female protagonist the bad
guys even though they're bad guys they
are at least polite and they have a good
sense of sportsmanship so they only
attack one at a time so there's a whole
group of bad guys and they just take
turns attacking the woman and then she
she you know knocks him each out with
one punch to the head
that's ridiculous enough as it is in any
action film
but then when you consider that she's a
member of this superhero team
and everybody else they have literal
god-like powers
and yet they have use for this 90 pound
five foot two blonde woman
because she can
throw a punch better than your average
blonde woman it doesn't make any sense
i'm sorry
professor logo says i like matt a lot
but i feel like he's missing the part of
the brain that allows people to have fun
he's like this in response to anything
that is just plain fun
no i think there are a lot of things
that that are fun i like fishing for
example
i could list other things that i think
are fun
um i'll get back to you on that in a
moment but
my issue here is that this is this this
actually is not fun you should not have
fun watching superhero movies they're
cynical
they're cynical in the way here's how
they're cynical uh
in the way that they treat the audience
okay the way that they treat you
they just give you the same slop over
and over and over again making no
attempt to tell an interesting or
different story making no attempt at all
just feeding you the same thing over and
over again
no because they assume that you'll just
come and watch it
because you have no respect for yourself
and the really sad things that
oftentimes their assumptions are correct
um
let's see dibs dib says
not a fan of hers wonder woman
but it's
femiskiren armor she has a healing
factor and super speed
justice league was better with the
bullet deflecting because zack snyder
actually made her move that fast
uh okay
mavericks doesn't like what i said about
the hulk because as the hulk is so much
more than that his powers are a
reflection and consequence of him being
abused by his father that anger and
depression is what triggers him to
transform into the hulk with gamma rays
and that's very adult and interesting
the man gets big and green and strong
because he's mad at his father
that's very adult and interesting
sorry but no seven-year-old can make
that up so easily that's exactly what a
seven-year-old would make up
that's what i point my point about the
hulk and uh yeah he is one of the better
superheroes but that's not saying much
you know it's a low bar
but he's also the kind of superhero that
every seven-year-old boy just invents
independently and then they discover
that this already exists out there at
least in the fantasy world it's just a
guy that gets big and green and strong
that's all it is
and so your your suggests you are trying
to rebut that claim by me
by pointing out that he only gets
he only gets like that because he's
angry at his at his parents
i think you just proved my point i don't
know but
thank you anyway to all the nerds who
responded to that
uh to that video and i'll take your
comments into consideration
before i just dismiss them out of hand
you know at the price of literally
everything skyrocketing there's never
been a better time to get your finances
in order yesterday ben released a brand
new episode of sunday special that uh
just might help you do that it's
available now at dailywire.com
dailywireplus.com rather that's the new
one dailywireplus.com this features a
very special guest best-selling author
of rich dad poor dad robert kiyosaki
that book is still as relevant as it was
when it first appeared 25 years ago with
the perfect storm of inflation and
recession and an educational system
that's turning people against the value
of free markets robert has something to
say about all of this and you want to
listen to his book his new book the
capitalist manifesto is a direct
response to these current times in this
episode of sunday special robert tells
us how he discovered capitalism growing
up explains the difference between good
and bad debt and how the bite
administration compares uh to that of
his longtime friend and collaborator
former president trump all of that in
this special speaking of great value
when you become a daily wire plus member
you also get access to our extensive
content library that includes
documentaries like what is a woman which
you may have heard of docuseries like
faucio mast hosted by michael knowles
jordan peterson's archive of content and
so much more help us build the future
that you want to see become a member at
dailywireplus.com
and check out the latest episode of
sunday special that's
dailywireplus.com today
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well it only took a month but finally
while i was away on vacation the
mainstream media deigned to acknowledge
the existence of my film what is a woman
which is still available to watch by the
way what is woman.com in an article in a
in the prestige scumrag new york
magazine titled the wright's dangerous
just asking questions anti-trans
campaign is working writer malcolm
harris
offers something of a i guess a review
of the documentary although as we'll see
he spends most of the time reviewing a
version of the film that i didn't make
but which he wishes i had made
so it begins with this claim he writes
quote over time words change stretched
by the practicalities of real world
usage or our language evolves and warps
it's an organic unavoidable and even
auspicious process now
we can already see the difficulty here
harris conflates
warp
and evolve
as though the two are synonyms
but they're not
and what could be more revealing
than somebody on the left thinking that
warp and evolve
are the same idea they're not at all
um what has happened to the word woman
in modern times and and so many other
words besides that one
is an example of language being warped
but it's not an example of language
evolving okay language evolves gradually
organically in order to make meaning
more clear in common usage but what's
happened with the word woman has not
been gradual it has not been organic and
it certainly has not made the meaning of
the word more clear
this is a top-down decree
from people with institutional power
simply declaring all at once that the
word no longer means what humans for
millennia thought it meant
not only that but
anyone who insists on the old meaning
is subject to various penalties
okay that's that's not language
evolution
that's always a good hint by the way
when there's when when language has
changed and
there's there are penalties put in place
for people who don't keep up with the
change that's a pretty good indication
that it's not actually evolution of
language
because evolut evolution of language
natural evolution of language doesn't
have its own law enforcement arm that
goes with it okay
this this is what it looks like when
language is forcibly warped
it's not what it looks like when
language evolves
harris can't tell the difference between
the two and that's his first problem
though it's certainly not his only one
now he continues the new anti-trans
documentary what is a woman begs its
title question not in the sense of
suggesting it but in the fallacious way
of assuming its own answer despite
mountains of evidence the movie's
producer is an on-screen guide
right-wing pundit matt walsh do not
believe that people can change their
gender actually as walsh reveals by the
end he doesn't accept that humans
express gender at all he hand waves at
chromosomes once or twice but he leans
hardest on common sense there are boys
and girls men and women males and
females penises and vaginas
mountains of evidence he says
now it should already go without saying
that harris never provides any of this
evidence there's a whole mountain of it
out there supposedly and yet he doesn't
extract even one pebble from this
mountain and present it to us
there's no link there's no citation
there are no examples
the mountain is invisible it would seem
but it's there okay and it's really
really big you guys but we just have to
take his word for it is all
next hilariously you know he heard you
heard me there you heard him there he he
chides me for
leaning hard on common sense
as if that's a bad thing
we already know that using common sense
is the ultimate sin the great heresy on
the left you're not supposed to rely on
common sense
that is you're not supposed to rely on
the fundamental understanding of reality
shared by nearly everyone who's ever
lived that's what common sense is
instead you're supposed to rely on the
uncommon and insensible sense of guys
like malcolm harris
and yet
merely a sentence after accusing me of
using common sense accusing me of it
harris switches gears and declares that
the film and all of my ideas about
gender are rooted in religious precepts
he writes quote by disguising a
religious precept as a reasonable
question walsh and his team have set out
to win new friends and encourage
existing allies at the same time it's an
effective strategy the majority of us
who understand the factual existence of
trans people can't afford to ignore them
matt walsh is a christian and he
believes that his god is the source of
our shared single nature he also
believes that his god is my god and your
god and everyone's god
quote god exists god is existence god is
reality god is permanent inexhaustible
unending god is identity the origin of
our own identity is found in god he
writes in 2017's the unholy trinity
blocking the less assault on life
marriage and gender transgenderism as he
calls it always in scare quotes
it means that man achieves his final
victory over truth and truth's god
okay it's clear from what he might
charitably will we might charitably call
his writings that walsh is a christian
fundamentalist who is personally and
professionally dedicated to making sure
god's law is a law and yet in his
biggest most prominent piece of content
yet
walsh never talks about his god at all a
curious omission in a movie about
reality and identity
now he goes on from here continuing to
quote a book i wrote five years ago
calling me a religious fundamentalist
he mocks ideas like transubstantiation
he calls fans of my movie my
co-religionists
now i hate to say i told you so uh to
those conservatives who criticized my
film for not having an explicitly
biblical message
but i told you so
it is strikingly clear from this new
york times mag this new york magazine
article that the opponents of the film
really wish that i had framed it in
religious terms
they want our arguments on this topic to
be entirely faith-based and biblical
they desperately need us to be seen as
making a religious case
because
they are making a religious case
they want the the war over biology to be
a holy war our religion against theirs
then we can't criticize them for being
doctrinal and dogmatic because we're
being the same way we would all be in
the same boat or maybe if not in the
same boat we would be in different boats
floating on the same sea
but there's no reason for us to play the
game on those terms
i am a devoutly religious person i of
course stand by everything i said in the
in my book that he quoted there all of
that is 100 true and i'm proud that i
wrote it and i'm glad that he quoted it
but um that has absolutely nothing at
all to do
with my conviction that women have
babies and men don't
okay i didn't learn that from my
religion and even if i didn't believe in
my religion i would still recognize this
truth just as i would know that two plus
two equals four no matter if i was a
christian or a hindu or a buddhist or an
atheist
they are the religionists on this issue
the writer of this article so badly
needs to argue the matter on religious
terms that he's simply inventing a
religious angle that doesn't exist in
the film and arguing against that
instead so he's basically saying
well you didn't make it this your
argument religious but i know that it's
really religious so i'm going to argue
against it as if it is
later he writes quote
what is a woman throws trans women's
existence into question
the form of inquiry can be divorced from
its content and to ask if trans women
are really women is not just asking
questions especially if a bigot deity
has already told you the answer and
especially if you're spending a pile of
cash on advertising
so there he is again bringing god into a
review of a film that as he admits or
rather laments never mentions god at all
he also says that the movie throws trans
women's existence into question
though of course
i don't at all question the existence of
people who identify themselves as trans
women
those individual human beings do
certainly exist
if they didn't there'd be no need for
the movie
what i question are the claims those
people make about themselves
so the people exist absolutely
um but they they make claims about the
world and about themselves and uh some
of those claims are incorrect that is my
contention
just as i don't deny the existence of
anorexics though i do deny the reality
and factual validity of their
self-perception specifically the
perception of themselves as obese i deny
that
more from the article says if you press
play on what is a woman which i advise
not doing with the accurate factual
knowledge that some women are trans i
have a hard time imagining anything
walsh has to offer will confuse you
anyone with some background on the topic
knows that the anti-trans interviewees
which include a hateful doctor a
regretful phalloplasty recipient and a
sore loser cis student athlete are not
representative figures
so we have another gear shift here as he
goes from
admitting that the film is devastatingly
effective i mean he says so right in the
headline to shrugging it off as sort of
weak and irrelevant he also demonstrates
how the transgender
gives men license to say things about
women that they would never get away
with saying otherwise
so here he just scornfully writes off a
young woman who simply wants a fair
playing field calling her a sore loser
that
men
can only talk about women and two women
in that way in the context of the trans
debate that's the only time that's ever
allowed
then um
after accusing me of deliberately
inciting violence he wraps things up
this way he says quote
if that's the anti-trans playbook then
walsh is a player coach leading by
example with what is a woman they've
spent millions to take the strategy to a
new level the plan is working this
year's pride month looks to have a
casualty count if walsh and his ilk are
successful next years will be higher
they're begging for it now bucking the
trend throughout most of the article he
does attempt to provide some evidence
for the pride month casualty count claim
so he links to an article in the
baltimore sun from a few weeks ago
about a row home fire in the city which
occurred across the street
from where somebody allegedly burned a
pride flag
and a few people were injured in the
house fire
now
there's no known connection between the
alleged flag burning and the house fire
so again it was across the street they
found allegedly a pride flag that had
apparently been burned
and then and then and then on the other
side of the street there was a house
fire
one did not cause or lead to the other
as far as anybody knows
no cause has been determined of either
fire
nobody knows if the house fire was
deliberate
and if it was we don't know why it was
started
so we know none of that whatsoever so
there are there are about four or five
leaps you'd have to make to connect the
house fire to anti-lgbt sentiment and
then there's another one or two leaps to
continue the connection all the way to
my film
yet this is the best harris can do
it's not his fault
it's very difficult to find real
examples of actual anti-lgbt violence
because it hardly ever happens
that doesn't stop him from suggesting
that there's an epidemic of a type of
violence for which he could not find
even one confirmed example
that of course is the common theme with
harris and his ilk
the facts don't stop them
they simply shout their bald assertions
and then cover their ears in case anyone
shouts back
that's why harris by the way locked down
his twitter account and went to private
as soon as his article was published
that's how you know someone's really
confident in what they wrote right they
publish it and then lock everything down
and go hide
and so
hiding under his bed you know he may not
be able to hear me say it but i must say
it all the same
to malcolm harris of the new york
magazine
you are today cancelled and we'll leave
it there for today thanks for watching
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomblin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2022
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire